- When the Jets get slaughtered
on Monday Night Football, I tend
to get the fuck out of town.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday morning
of your life?
4:30 in the morning.
Ready Avi?
- [Avi] Yes, sir.
- [Gary] Airport life.
("Drake-ish" by Fiifi Jr.)
You can like comments
now on Instagram.
- [DRock] Really?
- Instagram continues to
innovate at a rapid speed.
Engagement matters.
- [Woman] I think for 2017
that's one of YouTube's
biggest focus.
We're launching an ad product
called Attribute for Action and
Attribute for Shopping
so we're looking at
how do you put that...
- [Gary] I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
I started my career
as an entrepreneur.
I was born in the former
Soviet Union and immigrated to
the U.S. when I was a kid.
(audience applause)
Anybody have questions?
Anything like
very specific or...?
Yes?
- [Woman 2] What's next?
- I have no idea.
So I'm paying attention to
things but the truth is I don't
think we need to be
crippled by what's next.
Let's go back to TV terms.
That's like me being an NBC
executive right now and you ask
me what's the next hit show so
you can run a commercial on it.
The way I think about those
logos is they are the most
important things right now and
when "Seinfeld" and "Friends"
and "Empire" are the number one
shows you run ads against it and
when they're not, you don't.
I love when people ask me like,
"Well, Gary, what if Instagram's
"not here in four years?"
I'm like, "Well then we'll
spend our money somewhere else."
You know, I think
we have these different
emotional feelings towards these
new platforms that we did
not have towards television.
When "Seinfeld" canceled
you went someone else.
But I know emotion to where
the end consumer's attention is.
I've been studying
drive time radio.
Drive time radio prices
continue to come down.
They're gonna get low enough to
where I'm gonna be
like you know what?
I'm gonna buy that.
And what I try to do is
suffocate any debate by making
it a A/B test or a bake-off
between whatever you believe and
whatever I believe and then
let's deploy it on how much
(censored) are selling at
Albertson's in
the state of Missouri.
You run yours, I'll run mine
let's see and the three or four
companies that I've been able
to actually put in that corner
because I'm tired of debating
marketing mixes that were built
to justify TV spend.
Where is the common
sense against the math here?
Go take one outside math person
and have them audit the way
you're scoring internally
and they laugh.
It's built to justify
traditional behavior.
Let's make this about the ethos
of 2017 which is the fact that
we are looking to become the
number one storytellers in that
format and this is the account
that's giving us the most
at-bats, has the most upside,
we want to really show them and
let's make it an offensive move
instead of a defensive move.
Good talk at my (censored)
client's digital off-site.
Saw some fun characters from
Snapchat, YouTube,
all the players, Bustle.
Technical difficulties on the
flight from Chicago gave us
a little bit of a loop,
little curveball but
into our day now
here in Chicago.
Now having another meeting
with a potential client
and just a
whole lot of VaynerMedia
work today which is good.
You know?
It's what I do for living.
This GaryVee is my side hustle.
Super pumped to
be here actually.
Just thinking back to our
awesome Budweiser video that was
done in this great town.
Those Cubby fans, like
my best friend Brandon.
Actually put a little,
can we click within?
- [DRock] Nope.
- Got it.
Anyway, just put play the little
Budweiser video and we'll put
a link in the YouTube.
If you haven't seen the
Bud work by VaynerMedia.
Amazing job by the clients
creating the context and
the air cover, just really fun.
Alright, where's my lunch?
The amount of times
we take off this mic.
We have no interest in being
paid for something that we
aren't bringing value on and we
have no interest in nickeling,
diming any client.
You know, in any shape or form
so our intent
on whatever's needed,
how long, finish what is
going to be more predicated on
what's right for you guys
then what's right for us.
Period, end of story.
That's what client services is
in the right way and so I think
you know that which excites
me and so that's the truth.
I just want to reiterate that.
We'll assess and whatever's the
right thing to do as if we owned
all three companies,
your's, their's and mine
that's what we will do.
Yep.
- [Tyler] How
important is (censored)?
It's important call.
- [Tyler] Okay.
And then the Cavs game
tomorrow night?
- [Gary] Yeah.
Episode 102, I just finished it.
It's good.
It's real good stuff.
I think you guys
are gonna like it.
I think I look cute today.
Gonna be pretty subjective and
anecdotal to my mood right this
second but I would say that...
Waiting for a car, an Uber.
DRock is here, Tyler is here.
Kinda figured out
something new with Tyler.
He travels with me more now
and it's been more efficient.
That's kind of
an interesting insight
for anybody
that's really crazy.
I know most of you that are
watching are not rolling with an
assistant let alone willing to
pay for that assistant to travel
but for any of you that are
it's an interesting thing.
I did not think it
was to be a good idea.
It's turned out to be a very
good idea and just looking for,
always looking to hack and
we've just been more
efficient getting shit done.
So, I like that.
- [Tyler] Let's go.
- [Gary] Are we done?
Little side note,
Chicago lookin' right.
Had a bunch of meetings today
with clients and prospective
clients and wanted to put
some meat on this episode.
I just don't
understand salespeople.
It's actually a really
interesting trait that allows
somebody to be a
good salesperson.
It comes down to empathy.
Are you able to put yourself
in the other person's shoes?
I know what I want.
I know how I want it to be but
the reason VaynerMedia's been
successful is because I haven't
been stubborn about forcing all
my clients who are $9 billion
companies to do it my way.
I'm a little, I'm a speedboat.
You know, me as a brand,
as a person,
as a human, I'm teeny tiny.
VaynerMedia's small.
$100 million, small and so
you need to be empathetic.
I know how you want it to be.
I know when you're hitting me
up for 15 minutes of my time
what you want out of it.
What do I want out of it?
What do I get out of it?
And that's what I do 24/7/365.
I check my wants at the door
when I go in sales mode and
that's the flip reverse
of how most of the roll.
You see this?
You know, it's
always interesting to
see when you get into patterns.
Like right now I'm just deeply,
deeply entrenched and engaging
heavily into my
Instagram community.
Literally, it's been building
and then I come up with the
60 Second Club
and literally then
it's like the
universe gives back.
Today the hearting
and liking of comments
which allows me to even
scale my engagement even more.
Here's some love for KigPoppin.
Here's some love
for Bouchemanstep.
Here's some love for LuckyLore7.
You know what I mean?
Classic Gabe gets
some love, DRock.
Classic Gabe gets some love.
CitoRuiz, love.
Omar Seeray, love.
Fabulous Frederick, love.
NJWOfficial, love.
Cody Sudo, love.
Sage Speece, love.
Just love.
Daniel Ayialla, underscores
and dots everywhere, love.
Clash Brooks, can't
comprehend the grind.
You can do it, too.
We can all do it if you
know why you're doing it.
That's what matters.
- [DRock] Graphic right there.
- (laughs) Good job, DRock.
I already forgot after one day.
Kimberly Vincent
being smart, saying that
I would love to win
five minutes with Gary.
Not a physical gift, not even a
car and I'm replying that's...
That's coming soon.
You know, that's how we do it.
Hello?
- [Man On Phone] Hello?
- Yo.
- [Man On Phone] Hi.
- Hey, it's Gary.
- [Man On Phone]
Where are you today?
New York?
- [Gary] No, I'm in Chicago,
headed to the airport,
headed to L.A.
Living the dream.
(Man On Phone laughs)
When the Jets get slaughtered
on Monday Night Football
I tend to get the
fuck out of town.
(laughs) Think it's a huge,
huge flaw of most leaders.
To me, the thing
I am most proud of
is I could be
sold on anything.
And at the same time,
nobody believes in
their shit more than me.
You know? But fuck,
I'm open for business.
Did you see my face when
you came to me and said
maybe I should travel with you.
I'm like no!
But, you know, it's
turned out to be right.
Open for business.
- [DRock] Well it's what
you say all the time,
people draw lines in the sand.
- Yeah, I just don't want
to have lines in the sand.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Other than fuck you Patriots.
Fuck you!
You pieces of shit.
Is this yours?
Chicago I always do it to you.
In and out.
(laughs) It's the funniest.
I just don't know why I don't
have the ability to actually
stay in Chicago for the night.
It's just every time,
same thing.
I wish I could sing
'cause right now I'd sing
"Girl, You Know It's True" by
Milli Vanilli but
I just don't have it.
Girl, you know it's,
girl you know it's true.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
I love you.
("Drake-ish" by Fiifi Jr.)
- [Annoucement] The
moving walkway is now ending.
- Alright, alright,
alright, alright, alright.
I feel like I'm
Matthew McConaughey from
"Dazed and Confused."
Alright, we are picking somebody
right now on Instagram
for the 60 Second Club.
- [DRock] First one ever.
- First one, no, we've
done some signed books.
First one I'm
filming on DailyVee.
What we gave away on this one is
$200 deployed against
your pick of sneakers.
We like sneakers.
- [DRock] We do.
- We're wearing the
same sneakers today.
- [DRock] We are.
- [Gary] Which is devastating.
I heard Gary.
They're awesome and anybody who
wants to keep sending sneakers,
I'm super into it.
I'll continue to give shout outs
because that will excite people
to send me more sneakers.
10-and-a-halfs,
they can get love.
It's worth the $50 or $90
or $400 for the exposure.
Don't send sneakers, I'm good.
Here we go.
The first person to win
a pair of sneakers
is going to be
somebody very nice and sweet.
Very cool.
He's in the 60 Second Club,
just picking a couple people.
- [DRock] Are you
picking at random?
- Yeah, picking at random.
I'm just kind of, I'm looking
at what people, you know, people
that just put #60SecondClub
I'm looking for originality.
I'm looking for
anybody that's got,
is giving me love in
their profile picture.
That's a quick way to scam me
into winning something good.
So we're gonna go with,
oh, you getting in here?
We're gonna go with
FitnessJonesTraining.
Congrats, my man, you've won.
Congrats, my man.
And that's why I win.
The combination of
running the marathon.
I don't need it right now.
I'm patient as fuck and I really
give a shit about what you want.
It's why you like me.
It's why this content works.
It's why all these things work.
Because I think about you.
I don't think about myself and
so we need to deploy empathy.
You think you're a good
salesman, show me by deploying
massive empathy and
awareness to the other person.
They're not stupid.
They don't not get it.
They don't get it the way you
want it 'cause
usually it's for you.
Amount of you trying to sell
me right now in the comments on
Insta, I know what you want.
But if you're trying to sell
it to somebody you need to
understand what they want.
That just came out
of straight livin'.
Knowing what I just did the last
12 hours and then going in these
comments sections
and people just,
just not deploying empathy.
If you want something,
you need to reverse
engineer the other person.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
22 hours.
("Drake-ish" by Fiifi Jr.)